the Archbishop of Canterbury has used  his new year message to urge the  government to fix what he called the  UK's Broken Social care system Justin  Welby commended the queen on a life of  service and said families communities  and governments should perform their  service to the country's elderly our  care system is broken  but it doesn't have to be  we can rise to the challenge of fixing  it that means action from all of us you  me families communities government  in a few weeks time the Archbishop of  York and I will publish a significant  report on social care it will offer a  hopeful vision of our society  one where no one is held back overlooked  or treated as a burden  Jesus reminds us of the value of every  single person young or old  he challenges me to love everyone as I  know he loves me that's right I wish you  all a very happy New Year